people have been building boats to try
to go underwater for a very long time
like look at this old art where you can
see Alexander the Great going completely
underwater in a big glass Barrel this is
like 2 000 years ago 1800 years later
you have Leonardo da Vinci who was busy
literally thinking of anything that
could be invented and he sketched up his
very own version of an underwater boat
this beauty right here it was basically
like a big mechanical fish oh and this
is wild he kept these sketches a secret
because he feared quote the evil nature
of men who practice assassination at the
bottom of the sea like he thought that
we might use these underwater boats for
war
whoops